former senior advisor to the president
Stephen Miller along with Fox News
contributor Lisa Booth Stephen let's go
to the the foyer request that you and
your group made let's go to the hand you
redacted materials which are absolutely
useless they're specifically claiming
executive privilege on on emails under
pseudonyms to his son Joe Biden and what
he might have shared as it relates to
Top Secret uh or classified information
do we know anything more about that
yeah so this is really a staggering
development Sean after the Mar-A-Lago
raid we sent a foia request freedom
information act to the National Archives
demanding production of vice
presidential records from Joe Biden's
time as vice president relating to
Hunter Biden's business dealings and
Rosemont Seneca when they didn't reply
as required by a law and Obey that foia
request we took them to court we sued
them here in Washington DC as a result
of that litigation they have started
churning over large numbers of emails
which document how extensively the Biden
vice presidency colluded and
collaborated with Hunter Biden but
here's the kicker Sean in the last batch
of emails they redacted fully redacted
just wiped out blacked out disappeared
200 emails relating to Hunter Biden's
business operations in Rosemont Seneca
they asserted executive privilege over
200 separate Communications what is in
those emails Sean what is so sensitive
about the operations of our federal
government that Hunter Biden and
Rosemont Seneca had access to so we are
in court now we will press this issue we
will see if we can get access to those
emails or of course coordinating with
the incredible house oversight committee
and James Comer but we must get to the
bottom of what is buried inside these
redacted emails and by the way there's
more than that though we got 5400 under
pseudonyms that we'd like to get a hold
of all of them wouldn't we and uh aren't
these pseudonym Stephen Miller aren't
they being used to protect against or to
try and hide the fact that Joe Biden was
sending them
yes exactly so as you mentioned in
addition to the emails that were
conducted under Biden's own name you
have five and the names of his senior
advisors and staff you have five
thousand plus emails through a series of
pseudonyms this is what James Comer is
going to hopefully be able to get so
we're running these parallel
investigations with what I'm doing what
James Comer is doing but it is my
supposition that you will find in those
pseudonym emails and elaborate foreign
bribery scheme that will be game set
match for Joe Biden we've already
documented and you have gone over the
shop better than anybody the tens of
millions of dollars going into the Biden
family coffers at the same time as Joe
Biden is conducting favors for these
foreign countries and foreign business
partners those pseudonym emails in my
opinion will be the nail in the coffin
on the story I think you're right as
well and by the way James Comer and Jim
Jordan will join us Lisa great to see
you White House treating uh Joe like a
toddler you saw him walk out of that
that ceremony earlier today it was
beyond bizarre two-thirds the Democrats
say he's too old to run a dramatic
decrease in minorities his treatment of
the people of Maui the people of Florida
East Palestine just hasn't had the time
since March to go over to Ohio and help
the people out after the you know
they've lost everything in many many
neighborhoods now evacuated because of
the radiation Fallout
it's sad right because these people need
his help and he simply just doesn't care
and I guess you know 2020 was the
basement strategy and I guess 2024 is
the vacation strategy which which has me
concerned does it mean he's not running
or does it mean he already thinks it's
in the bag because the Democrat machine
is behind him you know and there's all
this talk about Joe Biden's age but
don't we want him to be the nominee
don't we want him to run again he is the
weakest and the most unpopular president
in modern history since Jimmy Carter so
we want him to be the nominee
particularly when we know that Democrats
are trying to criminally convict or a
potential nominee and also potentially
try to keep him off the ballot in
certain States invoking the 14th
Amendment so we should want to face the
weakest Democrat and that's Joe Biden
maybe outside of Kamala Harris so we
want to face Joe Biden all right so
question for both the Elisa we'll start
with you exit question will Joe Biden be
the nominee for the Democrats
uh
no because I I'm trying to be careful
after the midterms I know I'm sorry Sean
no don't apologize for being true to
yourself uh Stephen Miller
if if the House Republicans stand with
James Comer and Jim Jordan in their
incredible investigations Joe Biden may
very well be knocked off that bout but
we need every house Republican to stand
with those two great Patriots all right
Stephen Miller keep up the good work
update us when you can Lisa great to see
you joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else